à partir de demain à reims dans le huis
clos de la cour d'assises dès mineurs de
la marne pendant une semaine
patrick dils accusé du meurtre de deux
enfants commis en septembre 86 sera jugé
ou plutôt plus exactement rejugé et
c'est une première en matière pénale car
patrick dils condamné à la prison à vie
en 1989 il s'agit pour lui de faire
reconnaître son innocence
en s'appuyant sur la présence du tueur
en série francis heaulme sur les lieux
du crime au moment des faits valérie
ermite et jean-pierre miotto rappelle
les principaux éléments de cette affaire
et les témoignages contradictoires
là je vous montre la chambre de patrick
serrés ces lamelles de 14 ans lassé
collection de minéraux une collection de
pierres des livres des maquettes
l'univers d'un adolescent de 16 ans
patrick dils
le plus jeune condamné à perpétuité de
france le 28 septembre 86,2 enfant de
huit ans ont retrouvé morts massacrés à
coups de pierres le long d'une voie
ferrée
sept mois après le meurtre patrick dils
arrêtait passe aux aveux des aveux
incomplet mais extrêmement détaillé
renouvelée des aveux auquel les parents
de patrick n'ont jamais voulu croire que
ces aveux ont été extorqués souffle et
sauf et c'est sûr et certain que je mets
ma main au feu que ce soit était fait si
patrick dils avant de se rétracter à
vous il n'explique rien j'étais comme
obliger poussé à agir dira-t-il
pour son avocat patrick alors très
influençable a sagement répéter une
leçon apprise par la police elle même
il sera d'ailleurs le troisième à passer
aux aveux
les aveux qui n'explique pas l'essentiel
mobile du crime
encore une fois c'est quand même
incroyable patrick dils aurait en
l'espace de neuf minutes à mains nues
avec des pierres tué deux enfants qu'il
ne connaît pas pour tout câlin pas du
tout l'autre pratiquement pas changé
aucune raison serait rentré chez lui
aurait dîné auraient regardé la télé ils
seraient allés se coucher vraisemblable
il faudra attendre 1997 et un
rebondissement nommé francis heaulme
pour que la justice s'interroge le tueur
en série était présent le jour du
rim une information qui ne change rien
dans la conviction profonde des familles
des victimes
patrick dils et pour elle le seul
coupable il a eu des aveux à la chaîne
il a eu des abus il a commencé par rail
a fini par z il a tout du tout du tout
du tout du tout dix ans qu'on arrête ce
site et après il a dit je suis soulagé
bernard verley et l'ex directeur d'
enquête c'est lui qui a arrêté patrick
dix quinze ans plus tard les policiers
n'a lui non plus aucun doute
si on me démontre par a plus b que x est
l'auteur du double meurtre avec des
éléments concordants par rapport aux
constatations par rapport à ce que l'on
connaît
je serais étonné c'est impensable c'est
pas pensable conviction contre certitude
la justice elle a douté fait
exceptionnel patrick ville sera rejugé
par une autre cour d'assises à reims
avec derrière lui
l'ombre d'un tueur en série